[Música]
Brasil se prepara para nuevas protestas
de Seguidores de Jair bolsonaro hoy en
la tarde la plaza de los tres poderes
donde fue la toma del fin de semana está
cerrada pero se esperan manifestaciones
en otros puntos de Brasilia mientras que
la oea se reunió de manera
extraordinaria para rechazar el ataque
tenemos detalles desde Brasil
la economía y la energía fueron al
centro de la mesa bilateral que
encabezaron hoy el presidente mexicano
Andrés Manuel López Obrador y el Primer
Ministro de Canadá Justin allí abordaron
la operación de compañías mineras
canadienses y la financiación de ese
país para gasoductos
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos llegó a Perú para comenzar sus
indagaciones sobre la respuesta que le
han dado las autoridades a las protestas
anticobernamentales que dejan 47 muertos
y justo hoy en puno cientos de personas
salieron a marchar con los ataúdes de
los 17 fallecidos que hubo el lunes
ampliamos desde
Lima Bienvenidos a una nueva
actualización de las noticias del mundo
aquí en France 24 yo soy María Clara
calle iniciamos esta ronda informativa
en Brasil Los Seguidores del
expresidente Jair bolsonaro convocaron a
nuevas manifestaciones para hoy en
Brasilia y en otras ciudades del país
estas serían las primeras protestas
desde el 8 de enero cuando los
simpatizantes del ultraderechista
atacaron el congreso la Corte Suprema de
Justicia y la casa presidencial por otro
lado la oea se reunió hoy de manera
extraordinaria y condenó lo que llamó
acciones fascistas en Brasil Mientras
que el supremo tribunal Federal ratificó
que el Gobernador de Brasilia Ivana
isocha deberá apartarse de su cargo por
90 días y también avaló la orden de
prisión preventiva contra Anderson
Torres el ex secretario de seguridad de
Brasilia nuestra corresponsal Valeria
sacone tiene los detalles
Brasil se blinda ante el riesgo de que
se repitan los disturbios del domingo
pasado en los grupos de bolsonaristas
están convocando manifestaciones para la
retomada del poder en Brasilia y en las
principales ciudades de Brasil como Río
de Janeiro en la playa de Copacabana el
juez de la Corte Suprema Alexandre di
morais ha prohibido tajantemente que los
manifestantes corten carretera y envadan
edificios públicos las penas van desde
la cárcel hasta multas de 100.000 reales
es decir 20 mil dólares recordamos que
desde el pasado domingo hay una
intervención Federal en el Distrito
Federal que es donde se encuentra
Brasilia el responsable de la seguridad
de este territorio capelli ha dicho que
es imposible que se repita las mismas
escenas de hecho en ese momento la plaza
de los tres poderes está cerrada y no se
puede acceder además la mano dura de la
ley está cayendo sobre los supuestos
responsables de permitir los actos de
vandalismo del 8 de enero el gobernador
del Distrito Federal ibanéis Rosa fue
alejado del Poder y hoy la Corte Suprema
ha decidido que tiene que quedarse lejos
del poder o sea exonerado además el
responsable de seguridad del Distrito
Federal Anderson Torres va a ser
arrestado hay una orden de busca y
captura recordamos que Torre será el
exministro de justicia de Jair bolsonaro
se fue asumió el cargo el uno de enero
echó a los principales responsables del
dispositivo de seguridad de Lula se
marchó a Orlando a la misma ciudad donde
está ahora bolsonaro y anoche dijo que
volvería antes del tiempo para
entregarse a la justicia hoy no ha
podido de momento porque hay un caos en
el tráfico aéreo de los Estados Unidos
pero se espera que cualquier momento se
produzca su regreso y su detención
en Ciudad de México se reunieron el
presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel López
Obrador y el Primer Ministro canadiense
justido según el comunicado de la
presidencia de México los líderes se
concentraron en los temas energéticos
amlo dijo que la inversión canadiense
está creciendo en el país
latinoamericano a través por ejemplo del
gasoducto del Golfo de México además
intentaron zanjar las diferencias que
tienen Canadá y Estados Unidos frente al
gobierno de López Obrador al que acusan
de incumplir con el tratado de libre
comercio para beneficiar a las compañías
energéticas estatales sobre
inversionistas extranjeros amlo dijo
estar dispuesto a discutir esto con las
empresas canadienses por su parte
agradeció el trabajo conjunto y aseguró
que incrementarán la cooperación
México y Canadá siguen siendo amigos y
aliados extremadamente fuertes
Seguiremos hablando sobre cómo podemos
incrementar aún más nuestra asociación
económica nuestras asociaciones entre
personas y sobre todo la prosperidad que
ambos aportamos a la relación trilateral
en América del Norte que tanto tiene que
ofrecer al mundo
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos llegó hoy a Perú para comenzar
su indagación sobre la lo que ha
ocurrido en las protestas que ya
completan un mes contra el gobierno de
Dina boluarte y llegan un momento en el
que las tensiones no cesan justo hoy
ciudadanos salieron a las calles de la
ciudad de juliaca en el departamento de
puno exhibiendo los ataúdes de los 17
civiles que fueron asesinados en las
protestas del lunes las manifestaciones
se extendieron a otras ciudades como
cusco mientras que en puno esta noche
comienza el toque de queda nocturno
desde Lima nuestro corresponsal
Francisco Zacarías nos cuenta la
actualidad de las protestas en el país
Buenas tardes la superintendencia de
transportes reporta 61 puntos de
tránsito obstruidos y 12 vías nacionales
afectadas en puno la situación que hoy
empieza con el toque de queda en la
noche y también está de duelo se ha
visto reflejada con la movilización de
los pobladores quienes han cargado
féretros de las 17 personas que murieron
durante la jornada de lucha de las
últimas horas ellos visitaron algunos
puntos de la ciudad y esto ha sido como
una muestra de la situación de dolor que
vive en estos momentos el sur del Perú
Mientras tanto en cusco los
manifestantes se enfrentan a las fuerzas
del orden esta población trata de tomar
por la fuerza el aeropuerto José Velasco
astete Mientras tanto en Arequipa otra
región que también está en conflicto
algunos pobladores intentan realizar
saqueos mientras que otros tratan de
tomar la Plaza Mayor de esa localidad en
la situación respecto a Lima se
encuentra en tensa calma la capital del
Perú se va a convertir el foco de la
atención porque muchos manifestantes han
anunciado que van a trasladar las
jornadas de protesta a Lima también hay
manifestaciones en Venezuela los
empleados del sector público del país
protestaron este miércoles en Caracas
por tercer día consecutivo Y a esta
salida La llamaron la marcha de los
entierros pues para ellos el gobierno de
Nicolás maduro enterró simbólicamente el
salario mínimo y los sistemas de
Educación y salud los empleados
sanitarios por ejemplo dicen que lo que
ganan no es suficiente para subsistir
cuando un salario mínimo en Venezuela es
de cerca de 16 dólares
chile redactará su nueva constitución
política este año Así lo aprobó la
cámara de diputados con 109 votos a
favor 37 en contra y dos abstenciones lo
que sigue es la elección de los 50
miembros del Consejo constitucional
quienes escribirán la norma de normas
ellos serán elegidos por voto popular el
próximo siete de mayo y tendrán cinco
meses para redactar la propuesta y el 17
de diciembre el proyecto será votado en
un plebiscito Así es el nuevo proceso
constitucional luego de que en otra
refrendación la del 4 de septiembre del
2022 el 62% de los chilenos rechazaran
la primera propuesta de Carta Magna
cambiamos de noticia porque las nuevas
caricaturas publicadas por el medio
satírico francés Charlie edo revivieron
los reclamos por parte de Irán el medio
hizo una convocatoria para dibujos del
líder supremo de la República islámica
el ayatola Alika meney para conmemorar
los ocho años de los atentados en contra
de la redacción en París y hoy decenas
de iraníes protestaron frente a la
embajada francesa en Teherán Mientras
que el jefe del cuerpo de la guardia
Revolucionaria islámica José hin salami
sostuvo que los musulmanes se vengarán
tarde que temprano previamente la
politóloga Anita nasir nos explicó A qué
se debe la reacción de Irán tenemos que
entender todo esto como una típica
propaganda del régimen iraní cuando se
ve acorralado y encuentra que no tiene
otra salida que por ejemplo amenazar con
a este periodo satírico Como hizo en su
momento homena contra salman rusty por
lo tanto nos tenemos que lo tenemos que
entender En clave de la gran utilización
de los medios de comunicación del
régimen para desviar un poco también la
atención porque siguen reprimiendo la
gente siguen presionando las personas
que protestan contra el régimen porque
en Irán hay toda una maquinaria
represora que está contra la población
que está pidiendo No ya pequeños cambios
en un cambio total de régimen en
Afganistán el estado islámico se
atribuyó el atentado suicida que hubo
hoy en kabul A las afueras del
Ministerio de relaciones exteriores Este
es el segundo ataque que perpetra el
grupo en la capital en lo que va de 2023
después de la bomba en el aeropuerto
militar el pasado primero de enero en
cuanto a los muertos del más reciente
ataque no hay Claridad Pues por un lado
El Vocero de la policía de kabul sadran
afirma que fallecieron cinco personas
Pero el Ministerio de información
sostiene que la cifra es de 20 muertos
además según la cartera el atacante
pretendía explotar la bomba dentro del
Ministerio de relaciones exteriores pero
a la final no pudo hacerlo
en cuanto a la actualidad de la guerra
en Rusia hay un remesó dentro de las
fuerzas armadas el jefe del Estado Mayor
general valerieger masivov es el nuevo
comandante de la operación de los rusos
en Ucrania con lo que se degradó al
general sergey surobiquín quien tiene
una reputación de ser supuestamente
cruel con la movida Moscú espera mejorar
la estructura de mando el anuncio se
conoció después de que la milicia rusa
Wagner afirmara por segunda vez que
controla la ciudad de Soledad ubicada a
15 kilómetros al noreste de la disputada
bahamut y ahora el líder del grupo Jeff
Jenny sostuvo que mataron a 500
ucranianos que resistían allí los
detalles los tiene nuestra enviada
especial a Ucrania Catalina Gómez Ángel
el Ministerio de defensa ucraniano niega
que las fuerzas rusas tengan el total
control de esa pequeña población de
soledad en la región del donbas en la
provincia de dones como lo aseguraron
las fuerzas Wagner estas fuerzas
paramilitares que trabajan con el
ejército Ruso y que llevan meses
tratando de tomar el control
especialmente de la ciudad de backmuth a
pocos kilómetros de soledades esta es
una población especialmente importante
porque tiene unas minas de sal pero no
es una población estratégica en esta
campaña militar en la región del Don vas
pero sí sería Esa primera población que
ellos podrían tomar después de meses de
fracasos especialmente después de que
las tropas ucranianas tomaron o
retomaron el control de la región de
jarquí también de parte de la región de
jersona especialmente la capital ayer
anunciaban que tenían el control total
de esta pequeña sin embargo la batalla
continúa las fuerzas ucranianas dicen
que toda esta es una campaña de
desinformación para bajar la moral de
las tropas ucranianas que siguen allí a
pesar de las dificultades de esta lucha
también en backmud donde obviamente esta
campaña se intensifique donde las fotos
muestran que la ciudad está bastante
destruida los operadores de ambulancias
en casi todo Reino Unido entraron en
huelga por segundo día aumentando la
presión sobre el gobierno de Richie
sunak que buscó garantizar el servicio
desplegando a las unidades militares por
su parte los delegados sindicales
esperan negociar Un aumento salarial y
mejoras en las condiciones laborales la
historia la tiene Ramiro cueva Barberena
por segundo día consecutivo el personal
de salud de Reino Unido mantuvo su
huelga en casi todo el territorio
levantando nuevas protestas en distintos
puntos del país luego de que el gobierno
de Regis unak presentara un proyecto
para que los trabajadores presten un
servicio mínimo algo que aumentó el
malestar entre los trabajadores que hace
días se encuentran en disputa con el
gobierno reclamando mejoras en sus
salarios y condiciones laborales
el secretario de estado ahora lo tiene
muy claro entiende que resolver esta
disputada no va a ser hablar de salarios
para el futuro sino hacer mejoras en el
año de pago actual hacernos una oferta
de mejora antes del primero de abril
hemos sido muy claros al respecto el
secretario de estado ha reconocido esta
posición
este miércoles sunat manifestó su
preocupación ante las consecuencias de
un paro al que se hirieron alrededor de
25.000 trabajadores incluyendo
paramédicos Y ambulancias en este clima
de tensión miles de ambulancias fueron
operadas por unidades militares para
mantener el servicio
lo que es aterrador es que ahora mismo
las personas no saben si cuando llaman
al 999 recibirán el tratamiento que
necesitan
ahora señor presidente en Australia
Canadá y en Estados Unidos prohibieron
las huelgas en los servicios de Luz Azul
no estamos haciendo eso todo lo que
decimos es que en estos servicios de
emergencia los pacientes deberían poder
contar con un nivel básico de atención
que le salve la vida
Reino Unido está transitando un
levantamiento de trabajadores en varios
sectores a medida que los aumentos
salariales no logran mantenerse al día
con una inflación que alcanza los dos
dígitos y máximas de los últimos 40 años
así llegamos al final del informativo
los invitamos a que amplíen toda la
información internacional en nuestro
portal France 24.com ya que se unan a
nuestras redes sociales nos vemos en
minutos para más información
[Música]